and it's the start of another fall
semester so i'm going to give you some
pointers and the first is
don't sign up for my classes i
as a matter of fact
we'll cut down on the assignments and
just do some big high-stakes assignments
at the end of the course and maybe
around
midterms just like people have been
doing since time immemorial with
students there's no need to have a lot
of
activities that build on each other and
feedback it's enough for me just to give
you the apps that you so richly
so you know my advice to you as students
is
don't take my classes
because i don't really want to teach any
of you
as a matter of fact if you show up to
class
and you'll have to go track them down
yourself i'll write them on the board
very quickly and so you should have
already read that by the time that you
came to class if not
just shut up and sit there like a bunch
of mushrooms taking it all
in
what are we going to do over the course
of the semester well you can look at the
syllabus
you can look at the syllabus
but there's not going to be anything in
here that's tell you about what we're
until you find yourself in difficulties
so we'll put the information somewhere
else maybe a page
in the class website
even if you can't find it
we'll quiz you each day
at the beginning of class we use a lot
of paper as well because
why go green and why take advantage of
the course management system and
[Music]
so
let's bring ourselves back into the
1980s maybe we'll even mimeograph some
things for you we'll have pop quizzes
and maybe they'll have to do with the
material
maybe they won't maybe i'll test you on
all sorts of other things and of course
these will all
make sure that you have
proper
chicago manual style formatting with
lots and lots of footnotes which then
gives me an opportunity to use my red
ink pencil you got this wrong you got
this one
i'm going to be teaching you philosophy
which is you know a
discipline with a long long history
behind it
and we're going to try to make that as
dry
and dull
and inapplicable as possible
why shouldn't philosophy have something
to do with my life i'm not gonna be a
philosopher i'm gonna major in business
or communication
dentistry shouldn't philosophy
that's where you're wrong philosophy is
about thinking big thoughts
and see if they can actually fit
into your little non-philosophy
major heads of course if you are a
philosophy major
i'll be coming down harder on you
and calling on you and telling you how
you've got count for aerospace
that's how we do it in philosophy right
it's an adversarial
process so this should give you some
idea about what the semester ahead
holds for you
and you know if you don't like it i
suggest that you
switch instructors or drop the class or
drop out of school entirely wouldn't
that make your parents happy
and proud after they've invested so much
in your
future so that's it for the start of the
semester maybe we'll check in
later on around midterms
you